I appreciate y'all coming through man uh
41 is in the building I'm gonna let you
introduce you guys itself Kyle Jen is
here Mark krtg man you know y'all sorry
Force forever this is Jen Carter you
were we got Tata with us tonight head
off for me he gonna be here soon yeah uh
well welcome to La guys how's everybody
have you guys smoked a lot of good
California drugs since you've been here
we just got here oh you just got here
but trust me right after this interview
I'm on a yeah uh do you guys want to get
high during the interview yeah
wow we have a lighter
as long as you guys aren't 18.
you can't say no here [__] all that put
that [__] wait let me see that oh okay I
got this [__] for you
oh what's this what's that Big Al's baby
[__] yeah no I think this is uh this is
what we're gonna smoke though we're
gonna blow your face off pause
this is Mega series
yeah oh my God
oh he's already oh he's getting to it
it's called lemon Zonkers
smoke it bro not a lemon is better
though shout out to Gramercy man
some good [__] we'll have a nice stoned
interview
what's in this song uh that is uh it is
[__] gyoza Lemon Cherry gelato sugar
as well so you got some uh just take it
to the face it tastes like sugar yeah
it's good Welcome to California that is
good you know the crazy thing about New
York though is you guys are kind of
trying to be Cali now with the weed
except for you guys are way more
unregulated no you guys are like the
Wild Wild West for real with the weed
[__] now they go a lot of Wee we got a
different angle like this [__] is cool
I don't know if it's tweaking with this
gangster look at that [__] out of here
I don't even think I see it
you're overseas that's big out straight
from Northern California
where all the weed fields are nah Cali
got great weed oh yeah
you guys are just getting packs from us
all that [__] in New York is coming from
here
you just got a guy who got a guy and the
[__] gets put in the mail or someone
drives that's the [__] yeah yeah so this
is the thing about New York City now
right you guys can now go to like a
smoke shop and buy shrooms yo don't get
it
oh my God would you like to eat shrooms
bro let me say this is like yo try that
one the best spot I ever had bro
and I got the good shoes not the nasty
shoes
[Music]
you trying to shroom before the
freestyle is the real question yeah you
can do it yeah they said no no we're not
sure no okay it says no man it's okay
you remember the last time healthy drug
the last
everybody
sticks
shot the tops go find them this is my
[__] so
um so you guys are from uh Brooklyn
right yeah
[Music]
my favorite rap groups ever
Brownsville home of the brave putting
work in the street like a slave what you
know about that like one of my favorite
rap groups ever oh [__]
is Brownsville still because there was a
double XL article when I was a little
kid and they interviewed MLP and I
remember they were talking about how
they would like they were just saying
how crazy Brownsville was I always just
assumed Browns was like the craziest
place on Earth is it still that bad oh I
mean it's probably worse yeah
the gentrification hasn't hit
Brownsville yet I mean they trying right
but it's not doing nothing
because the danger the crime is scaring
the white people away yeah
and the hipsters
well ladies who don't shave their
armpits all types of shoes independent
coffee shops
you know never go to a Starbucks you
gotta support the Indies